Elizabeth Smart in her first sit-down
interview since getting word of release
of one of her kidnappers
Wanda bar Z is all set to be freed
tomorrow after Utah officials determined
that they miscalculated the 72 year old
prison sentence bar Z and Brian David
Mitchell were convicted for their roles
in smarts abduction and captivity that
lasted for nine months beginning in 2002
in an interview that you'll see only on
CBS this morning
Elizabeth opens up about how bars he's
coming release changed her do you still
believe that she's a danger why did why
do you feel that way I do believe she's
still a danger through my sources I've
heard that she's still carrying around
this book of revelations that Brian
Mitchell wrote that said that he should
kidnap me and not just kidnap me but six
other young girls and that would all be
his wives clearly she hasn't let it go
according to the justice system she has
served her time despite the
miscalculation that was made and people
could say but that's the way our justice
system works she did a terrible crime
she has paid the price what do you say
about that I would say this whole
situation circumstance has really given
me a greater appreciation and
understanding for how all of those
thousands of victims whose cases never
even make it to court whose perpetrators
who are walking free from the day that
they violated them or raped them or
kidnapped them or hurt them in any way
and nothing was ever done and this case
did this case did receive some measure
of justice but I think it's given me a
greater compassion and understanding for
how all of those victims and survivors
must feel and it makes me really think
that I don't think that this justice
system is a victims system you've also
said that you're grateful for the
experience help us understand that
I mean it changed me as a person I
wouldn't have the voice that I have
today I wouldn't have the compassion or
the empathy that I have today I wouldn't
understand what it's like to you know
walk the proverbial mile in their shoes
but I have have been there I do know
what it's like when you first went back
home did you live in a state of feared
were you constantly concerned about your
safety I was still concerned but I
wasn't consumed I liked that concern but
not consumed you're a very private
person but you decided to share this
story in hopes that it would help others
for years after I was rescued I I didn't
want anyone to know what had happened
truthfully I think I was ashamed and I
was embarrassed I didn't want people to
know that I'd been raped I think I got
to a point where I just felt like this
is not okay no survivor should feel like
they have to hide what happened to them
and serve I like need to be the girl
who's known for being kidnapped and
raped then so be it if it's gonna help
promote change and if it's gonna help
other survivors move forward with their
lives and not feel ashamed of what's
happened fine I'll do it that's a
powerful thing she said that there that
she didn't want anybody to know and then
she started thinking why am I the one
that's ashamed yeah she tells really
horrible stories about them coming home
with the Flyers with her picture on it
laughing saying everybody's looking for
you but they're never gonna find you
because we have you and you're never
gonna get away from here and she started
thinking about her life and thinking how
she could help others and now she's
married she's been married for a while
she's 30 years old guys she's got two
children she's seven and a half months
pregnant now and she says she's happier
now than she's ever been
you know like she's found a place for
this as she said to you that phrase I'm
concerned but I'm not consumed by it I'm
isn't that great to think you could be
in that place about something that is
troubling you and what she's been
through in her life now that this woman
who was
second abusable really both of them but
it's interesting you picked up on that
too because when she said that the hairs
on the back of my neck stood up
concerned but not consumed she's a very
smart very poised very capable woman
who's going to do great thing and is
doing great things very much and when
she said that this experience when she
talked about all the great benefits of
this experience and reminded me of John
McCain who said his five years in prison
you know that he wouldn't have changed
that because of web the person that he
made him to be to be able to take that
kind of experience and and use it as a
rock to stand on is a real amazing news
and forgive you know she says I've
forgiven I don't give them any thought
forgiven and I've moved on because you
know we get another girl thank you Oh